welcome back to las vegas now earth day
is on the 22nd of this month so i
stopped by findlay toyota to see how
they're saving your pockets
and our plan take a look
rocky hey john you didn't hear me coming
up
i sure didn't i knew you didn't john how
did this giant van sneak up on me like
that how's it so quiet
it's a hybrid it's a hybrid it's a
hybrid
and luckily we came up with the
technology
oh you know and i said you came up with
the technology well i could say that i
could credit myself for that but
actually i'm not a direct member of the
family i'd like to think i
am but the technology being the electric
and gas
combination and it's just unbelievable
but the mileage is
astounding yeah is that your favorite
part of driving a hybrid i know you
drive one as well
it is i drive a toyota avalon and even
with current gas prices you're in a
situation where you fill a tank up
for less than 40 dollars and you can
drive up to six hundred miles
what it's a umbrella forty and i drive
up to two hundred something so well
i'm not now i'm thinking i need a hybrid
i think we can probably get the handle i
got brittany here
oh hey girl hi she's gonna tell me how
it all works she's gonna tell you
everything because it takes some getting
used to yes it does
different yes it does cool because i'm
looking at this benzo right now so this
is avenza
newly redesigned got a new facelift uh
came back in 2020 discontinued in 2015
and now it is absolutely gorgeous
um it has not only awesome technology
inside but it's also a fully hybrid
vehicle as well now
nice okay can i get inside a real steel
yeah hop in oh yeah okay
i can see myself right in this for sure
you know it's comfortable it's also fuel
efficient
um but yeah okay so let's talk about
just the difference between a regular
car and a hybrid like like i said
i'm paying 40 dollars to just go 200
something miles yep
yes yeah so the major difference is
going to be the components within the
engine so
a traditional gas engine just has a 12
volt battery and you know petrol engine
that's running everything inside
with your hybrid you have an electric
motor and a gas engine working hand in
hand to give you the most fuel
efficiency
so like the lower speeds you're all
electric higher speeds you go into gas
it just keeps it nice and even for you
and i feel like this is a great car for
any age group
and especially people who are passionate
about saving the planet right it's clean
energy
yeah absolutely so your carbon emissions
can be cut in half when you're driving a
hybrid vehicle in comparison to just gas
right
it's a lot more cost efficient as well
like you said so i mean you're paying
what forty dollars to go 200 miles yeah
this is forty dollars to go 600 miles
which is absolutely awesome and you can
get a hybrid you can get a hybrid
corolla for
24 000 bucks i mean so it's good for all
ages and
and anybody who's passionate about the
environment and for that awesome price
you also get
the works on the inside let's talk about
the system in here
yeah so that middle console there um
it's a fully touch screen display
it comes with apple carplay android auto
um so all of your apps and everything
that are compatible with your car now
show up there which is super fun and
cool
um it also is compatible with alexa so
you could say alexa start my car and
it'll be ready for you
play with something perfect for a road
trip
everyday car as well absolutely i'm i'm
convinced
yeah i'm going hybrid get a hybrid tired
of paying 40
for 200 miles save the world and save
your wallet
all right call findlay automotive in
henderson the number is 702-566-2573 or
you can just visit findlaytoyota.com